[Music]
[Applause]
luno
the fastest easiest way to buy crypto if
you're just getting into bitcoin
it's the perfect place to start
hey guys and welcome back to my show
hope everybody is doing great today
um this is powered by icon plus so a
quick news announcement for you so in
march
icons user-friendly d5 project balance
will be released a dow platform that
creates icon tokens pegged to real-world
assets
like the dollar gold and oil now i want
to say thank you to my sponsors block fi
so i use them to earn up to 8.6 interest
on my usdc
you can also get 250 up to that when you
sign up so i'd really recommend them i
use them
they're doing incredible stuff now
before i bring on my guests who is a
really good friend of mine
um i also want to give a quick shout out
to coinflip
so they are doing amazing work across
the states and to push bitcoin mass
adoption
they have over a thousand atms and you
can actually get 10 off um transactions
with them so
i will leave a discount code for you now
guys if you are watching on youtube
please don't forget to hit the like
button and subscribe
so you never miss any of my fantastic
guests
so joining me today is a really
brilliant friend of mine somebody
that i think is doing amazing work in
the space it is of course
bitcoin liz what's up hey
thanks for having me on once again i
really really enjoyed it last time and
uh yeah it's great to be back always fun
to have a chat with you
about crypto and everything that's going
on in the world
yeah it's good to chat to you um i feel
like we both have um
really similar kind of perspectives on
things um
so it's really cool to bounce off each
other so this week has been
absolutely mad um we've seen tesla get
in
um to crypto 1.5 billion dollars um
you know on their balance sheet so what
do you think about this because
before before we jump into it i just
want to say that i've done a lot of
videos about this with on tick tock
right
and it's quite unbelievable how much
negativity there still is towards
bitcoin
yeah like i get people saying to me all
the time it's not true
it's a scam and i'm like it is true yeah
they did put 1.5 billion and
what are your thoughts yeah so first of
all comment on that
it's it's always the the ones who have
negative thoughts about it they probably
are like regretting not getting into it
earlier so they're just you know mad and
spreading all that but
because i mean you and tiktok you get so
many views you're like super huge
people find it interesting so yeah i i
it's
always that the negative people you they
are the loudest
but actually i think uh yeah people are
changing their mind and
specifically looking you at tick tock
it's amazing what you do i think that's
a
huge part of uh yeah getting people
to know more about bitcoin but yeah as
you mentioned with
with tesla and all that uh really focus
has turned uh towards bitcoin and
uh no one can ignore it anymore and and
i have
like previously also uh in my latest
video spoken about that i have
like old co-workers that i work with
long time ago reaching out to me and
asking about it and
i yeah so so people are really
interested these are the same people
that i spoke with them about bitcoin
like
two years ago they had no interest in it
so
i think even though we still might hear
the negative thoughts about
it people are actually really interested
in in bitcoin and
yeah a lot thanks to tesla and elon musk
being uh
going out and saying that he supports it
if the world's richest man does it
i mean something that that's really
something to keep an eye on uh
i believe at least yeah i think you make
a really interesting point you know you
have
people who we knew from years ago
calling up and asking us you know how
how can i buy bitcoin
so i kind of want to talk a little bit
about that because i often find that um
i have people that i went to school with
i have um
my friends and parents messaging me and
so on
asking me how they can get in and i
often feel
some responsibility and concern about
onboarding new people into the space um
i think that
you know even something as simple as
sending bitcoin from one
wallet to another i think has its
complications
understanding what a wallet address is
it
it takes some sitting down and
explaining
so my concern is number one i don't have
necessarily the time
to sit with somebody and go through the
whole shebang you know
um so how do you do it you don't really
want to do it half-hearted because then
if there's a problem they'll come back
and blame you
you know if they get their funds stuck
somewhere so
what do you do when people ask you and
you obviously don't want to be rude and
sort of say yeah
yeah i don't know what do you do so
actually i have got
the exact question that you're proposing
now
about asking do i need a wallet how do
you actually
send transactions and one one of my
previous uh
classmates from school he actually asked
about it and he was like oh i paid this
miners fee what is this you know so
yeah i as you said it takes time to
explain
and i'm not sure like what level they
are at uh they were asking about
okay sushi and in the sushi swap and all
that so i was
like thinking that okay he has probably
done a little bit of research but
in the end i i think just what i do is
uh
redirect them to good pages that i find
uh really for
simple to to read about i think binance
has like their academy that is super
super like easy to
so those are really for beginners and
just good articles because it takes too
long time to
uh to explain and at some point they
have their own responsibility to do
their own research about it like and
understand
so linking to good uh good material
is what i do and then of course try to
explain as good as i can
with my own words but yeah it's it's
difficult
uh but i i don't feel that we have the
responsibility to
do that of course we can just encourage
them and get into and
read more about it like this is really
interesting if you understand it it's
super cool but go and read here
because i think it's important that they
read with their own words and
and get their own understanding um yeah
that's my thought on it at least how do
you do it yeah i mean it just terrifies
me honestly because
when bitcoin when we had that initial
bull run earlier this year
i had a lot of people asking me how to
get in and i think that's fantastic and
i do
really really want to help but it's it's
a
to get somebody in who knows nothing is
really a matter of holding somebody's
hand um and
number one you know that that takes time
and we've all got sort of like jobs to
do and so on um
but i i'm just i'm not genuinely i'm
just a bit afraid
of um something sort of going wrong
and it being my fault because you know i
had somebody
say to me um just here's like a general
example someone asked me a question
what exchange would you recommend so i
thought okay well
gemini's really cool um you know try out
gemini
um they're really cool check out luno
whatever and
i think they went for gemini just
because they knew the winker boss twins
so they were like cool we'll go for
gemini
um and i said great then they asked me
what do you use and i said well i use
this platform and they said
well why are you using that and i'm
using this and i was like oh that's how
we're going to have a problem because
a lot of the time people who are already
in the space aren't using
those kind of on-ramp and off-ramp um
exchanges
they're using things let's say like
crypto.com as an example or blockfi as
an example
um you know it's different because that
takes i think a level of
um understanding it's not like your
first port of call when you get into
crypto
so i don't know i'm still trying to work
it out um i'm just you know
and then i think he i think that's the
same person sort of asked me like um
it's asking me to do like a wire
transfer what is that
and i'm like well if you don't know what
that is i can't help you
i get afraid i don't i just don't want
to be held responsible essentially
i agree i agree uh with because the
interesting part is that i think um now
that the friends that or old friends
that have
contacted me lately they are not
interested in bitcoin they're asking
about
other alts that are discovered and that
makes me
like a little bit afraid because they're
like okay is there anything else you can
recommend i'm like
i have just told them like take a look
at east it's easy to unders you know
like like they're like okay but is there
anything else you can recommend i'm like
no no you have to look on your own what
do you like
what you need to like the project you
need to understand it
and then you can invest but yeah so that
kind of advice i i don't want to give
either
because it's risky especially for those
who are not that involved in crypto and
for them it's maybe just enough that i
mentioned one project they're like okay
they said this i'm gonna go in and
not even read about it what what they do
or
or anything so yeah it's tricky it's
because you don't want to be rude as
well as you said
but you don't want to give them too much
advice that they can later come back to
you and say like hey this is your fault
so yeah yeah i think you then you make
an interesting point like everybody's
looking for that low-cap gem
um that's that's just gonna go you know
they're looking for that that doge or
they're looking for that i think uma was
not over 100
the other day um and i for me personally
i i sort of turn around and say
look like for me i see bitcoin as that
long-term
store of value um i think eth is really
interesting i do believe
it's undervalued right now so i'd say
check that one out
everything else i believe is um
very much to do with how you feel about
that project um
and whether you like the fundamentals of
the project or not then you can do your
own research from there um
and everyone's sort of like but
bitcoin's too expensive um
i had a friend actually text me and she
said and she said
um leia shall i get doge it's so cheap
right now tell me i'll do it
i'm like whoa how do you respond to that
if they should buy dojo for bitcoin you
just say like
sorry i i can't advise you on that i
don't know it's tricky
but i the the point really that you made
with that everyone thinks that bitcoin
is too expensive i experienced the same
thing with
one of my old co-workers and he said
like i'm not he was like
completely sure i'm not getting into
bitcoin because it's too late now it's
too expensive
so i'm gonna find these the other ones
and this was the same day when elon musk
went out and said that he supports
bitcoin on clubhouse and i was just like
think you will go in bitcoin the same
day or the same time as elon musk you're
not too late
but yeah yeah there's a lot of newcomers
who uh
who think that way right um and yeah and
then they want to go for doge or
something else that you mentioned so
yeah
it's crazy newcomers and like retail
investors
aside it's been a really interesting
week so i've got a list here so actually
i don't have a list here i have it
somewhere else but i do have mastercard
written down so
martial is a really interesting one
because they um i believe have confirmed
that
um they will start um allowing people to
actually
use cryptocurrency on their network so
we don't know which cryptos yet
from my research i believe it's going to
be very much stable coin focused
um which is cool i think that's really
cool i think people in the space
that will want to be that will have
cryptocurrency to spend
or people that will have cryptocurrency
spend will be people in the space who
therefore don't really want to be
spending their bitcoin so
having it a stable coin focus will be
really cool but it's down to
the merchants and whether the merchants
want to accept
bitcoin so what do you think do you
think
the likes of starbucks you know your
everyday coffee shop is gonna be
um down with this i mean
yeah now with the mastercard news of
course i think there might be
now it seems more likely that it can
happen at some point i thought it was
quite far away
but it would be interesting to see what
what the mastercard thing actually will
mean and as you said which
cryptocurrencies they will
support but i think it's closer than we
think yeah for sure
uh you can do it already now with some
crypto cards that you have that you
you have so so why not uh i think it's
it can be doable of course uh but it
yeah it's going to be really interesting
to see exactly what
what it means and what they what they
have planned uh with the crypto part
actually
because now with they haven't come out
and said really much right they just
said that they're gonna know
so so what we know is that it's
definitely not gonna be
um like a crypto card like we currently
have so i think mastercard are the ones
that have partnered with
um the other crypto cards like um wirex
and up hold
so it's not going to be a matter of just
take you know when you like top up your
card it changes to fiat it's not going
to be like that it's going to be actual
crypto
um and i think that's insane and i i'm
personally just so excited to see
what this means um i think it adds so
much credibility to the space like i
said yeah
there's so let's just like take tesla
versus this mastercard news
i understand that they're different but
i really think the mastercard news is
actually bigger
just because it means something to the
average day person so
yeah okay tesla kind of solidifies
bitcoin as that store of value and it
gives it credibility
but what does that mean for your friend
that's not in crypto well it doesn't
really mean anything because some people
don't want to buy bitcoin and have it as
their store of value
they don't even think they need a store
of value but yeah
and then also and then also in terms of
like actually paying
i think this mastercard news gives
crypto an even stronger use case
um for those outside of the space yeah
that's a really good point
when you put it that way it totally
makes sense because as well like
everyone has
some at some point had probably a
mastercard credit card so they they can
relate to that
uh with with tesla and elon musk i know
there's a lot of people at least like
like in sweden and who who think he's a
little bit crazy you know
a little bit special so they can be like
oh it's just because you know
he's like that but at the same i don't
buy i don't buy that
that argument at all but that can be
something but as you said mastercard
adds
a lot of credibility and uh yeah problem
is maybe a bigger bigger news um
true very true and also another i'm not
sure if it's confirmed yet
but blackrock is it uh at least like
they bought a few weeks ago yeah i think
they did it
okay so now maybe it is confirmed so i
think more and more like
investment companies and like that will
probably see it as a
like natural way to go as well and that
will even add more
credibility uh to to bitcoin uh so it's
yeah i think the fact that we are dark
web
intern money it's just forget about it
and now it it
there's too many things pointing the
other direction and
uh there's something for everyone that
they can relate to and understand
and yes why it is uh yeah good
and somebody's just put in the comments
someone just put in the comments um
i'll put it up on the screen actually
somebody wrote um
what are the tax implications if we use
crypto to buy a cup of coffee
so that's actually a really cool
question um i honestly don't entirely
know
um but i think that's going to be
something that will have to be solved i
think the tax issue i think the tax
topic is still really complicated
because then it's different
in every in every i'm just gonna say
state i'm not even american
it's different in every state it's
different in every country it's
different in every jurisdiction
um what i think um in terms of the way
that i do it
i guess if you get paid in bitcoin you
would
naturally write down or you know
you you would account for every single
payment that you've received
and then if you go buy a cup of coffee
with bitcoin and it costs you x
amount of satoshi's then you would have
to
obviously record that um but then again
if it's your party but then again i
guess if it's your personal money then
and you've already paid tax on it then
it doesn't matter but then i guess if
there are the
capital gains and you're holding your
money in bitcoin it doesn't matter i
mean
i couldn't tell you i absolutely don't
know it's still something i'm learning
myself
i think because now for example with i
have the pluto's card
and if i use it here in sweden i need to
account for every transaction i do with
it so
there is more work with it so probably
as it looks like right now it would be
the same in most countries
for for this mastercard thing but
assuming how big they are they would
probably think about a better solution
that is
easy to use for everyone because
otherwise it kind of loses uh
its purpose uh people don't want to have
more work to do or more
accounting to do because they want to
use crypto
on their on their mastercard and also it
is stable coin
based so yeah i'm not sure how
how how the implications will be given
if it you know is pegged
to your local currency then it will be
like using your local currency um but
also
bny melon um so they're actually the
oldest bank in america i actually i
don't know a couple of people that used
to work there
so they are now um able to be bitcoin
custodian so
this is interesting because it kind of
plays off against the narrative you know
um not your keys not your coins but then
at the same time
new people getting in especially the
especially the kind of clients that bny
mellon would have who come from a more
traditional kind of background
might prefer to have um their
cryptocurrency
in the custody of somebody else they
don't have to have that responsibility
so in terms of let's just talk about
mass adoption because i kind of feel
like this is what it is
how do you think that's going to go do
you think that people are going to
feel they don't really want the
responsibility of holding their own keys
um do you feel that having these cus
these custodians
coming into the space is actually quite
a healthy thing for adoption
good good question i think that if you
look at how how it is today
we the majority of people they trust
the banks a lot with all kinds of
information about this so i think
naturally for the bigger mass
they will probably don't want to have
access to or
be the ones responsible for their keys
um
that's just an initial thought but the
whole
idea with crypto at least we who are
here now
is that we should be the ones
responsible for it and the ones who
uh have responsibility for so i think
there will be probably
two parts to it um depending on how deep
you are
into it uh yeah i i don't know yeah i
haven't actually thought about that so
much
uh interesting but what do you think how
it's yeah
i can't help but think that those um
people that would be with clients of bny
melons
would appreciate having their
cryptocurrency
in their custody i can't help but think
that um
and that's not just their own clients
but i think it's the majority of people
and i think
if we look at the way society votes if
we look at the way society is run i do
think people
a a large a large majority of the
population definitely
enjoy a lack of responsibility over
certain sorts of things
um and i can understand that when it
comes to your finances i think it's
it's really scary you know to think well
i am actually responsible
i need to remember the seed phrase i
need to
remember my private keys my public keys
i need to um have it
written down or do i not want it written
down just in case you know do i keep it
in my head what if
all these different things and and i can
totally understand the
the why that's scary i mean if i'm
really honest
i often find i don't even like so i use
2fa obviously
and but i don't really like it um you
know
i'm just concerned that i'm going to
have an issue with my phone or my laptop
and i know there's ways to recover it
they have like the equivalent of a seed
phrase and so on but
it's still it still freaks me out and i
think
in terms of mass adoption that is going
to be the kind of
um way we're going to see things go i
don't think
people will be like you and i and be
like not your keys not your coins
yeah yeah exactly then we can see of
course just with the regular passwords
how many people forget the rest
of those normal we do it you know so
yeah probably will go that way that's um
and i think people will be fine with it
they probably just would want to have a
part of uh
like crypto as an asset and don't care
about having the
the ownership or the responsibility of
the priority
yeah i think that's what it is because
if you think about it the everyday
person
isn't um investing in the stock market
it's just not happening right
um a lot of people um are talking about
a lot of people are waking up to this
kind of
idea of inflation and okay well you
should be investing in the stock market
then
your average person doesn't do that so i
feel like cryptocurrency
um the old coins will sort of i think
fair in an equivalent manner in that
people don't really choose
the average person who doesn't know how
to change how to trade
won't necessarily play around in those
markets um but in terms of having
um in a pre uh an appreciating asset
then i definitely think people will be
choosing bitcoin and i don't think that
they're going to
care whether it's in the custody in the
course
i kind of say that word today the
custody of themselves
or a custodian um i just i don't think
they're going to care so much
um but let's talk about eth because you
are bullish on eth as
always so give me your give me your
thoughts on each
price this week it's nearly hitting um
2k yeah i think it will first of all i
need to check the price now
where
so definitely i think we should reach 2k
very soon
like like this week for sure um and
after that i still think it is
sleeping like hell we i i don't
understand why we don't take off yet
um but i think it will definitely happen
even though i mean
bitcoin might go down and eastwood might
like go up
and i still think that it is uh
yeah sleeping totally because just if
you think about all
the everything that's been going on
around d5
it needs to be involved in that and
that's that's where everything is built
now
i know many are like really critical
towards it because of the gas fees that
they're really high
but it's insane honestly there's yeah it
is but at the same time
there's so much going on and there's um
so many gains being made
so just everyone needs a fast
way to transact so then yeah they are
willing to pay more
so these if you have a transaction that
is worth like millions of dollars
then a fifty dollar eat fee gas fees
is um is not that like significant it's
because they need to have it fast and
that's when they're when they're willing
to pay more
and when it comes to everyday
transactions smaller transactions
i saw you posted about finance and their
pancake swap um
as well that can be like a replacement
for eth when it comes to
all these smaller transaction everyday
transactions that are super cheap
because basically what they've done they
have copied it but it's just
much cheaper so i think that part can
solve the
the one the part that everyone is so
critical about when it comes to it why
it's so expensive because for the big
transactions
it's not expensive people are willing to
pay that for everyday
smaller transactions yes i understand
that people are um
yeah a little bit angry about the gas we
but
then we have yeah pancake swap for that
instead for example
yeah i think you make a good point those
gas fees are pretty insane um
i actually tried to send well i didn't
try i did i sent um about 70
um and i in usdc maybe i don't remember
um and i think i paid
22 in gas fees which is totally
unacceptable and it's literally theft
um so my
kind of analysis and perception on all
of this is i definitely see value
beneath i think it's undervalued um as
it is
um you know like i said there's there's
like you said sorry there's a huge
there's a huge um need and narrative for
decentralization particularly when it
comes to
um apps yesterday um youtube took down
one of my videos for
absolutely no reason yeah yeah we can
talk about that and remind you okay
um yeah we can talk about that so later
down on my video so there's a need and
an argument for it i just
wonder whether there will be other um
networks
that other chains whatever blockchains
that will just
do it better um i wonder whether it's
kind of like
ethereum is this let's just call
household name i realize it's not a
household name yeah but
you know they've they've gotten to a
place where you know it's ethereum and
they've built a name for themselves and
and it's it's the go-to
it's the go-to um protocol everything's
being built on top of it
but i just wonder if something else i
don't know like tomo chain or something
like that could come along
finance chain um all these different
things could potentially
come along and take over i don't i don't
know i just think those gas fees
are left in my opinion yeah yeah when
you put it that way of course
they they seem like that but i think in
the long term it won't matter because uh
people will still continue to transact
with it the ones that the big
transactions
um i think will be done there and
and and still i think the important part
with ethereum
is the community it won't go anywhere
people are so like
hardcore building and i think that
matters a lot
of course there might come other
solutions but
they're probably not going to take over
it so to say
probably there there can be better um
solutions of course
but i think it's it's like with bitcoin
you know everyone knows about it it's
impossible to
you know it's it's impossible to to take
over and i think we're a little bit in
in the same situation with it and but i
said
people can use other possibilities for
those smaller transactions so they avoid
the
the high gas fees um so it's just
you have other options you don't need to
to choose or use
it for for those smaller transactions uh
so i think it won't disappear anyway but
i
completely hear how frustrating it must
be if you send like
yeah sixty dollars and you pay twenty
dollars for emp that's that's insane
that's insane yeah yeah it is pretty mad
and i'm just hoping
um and i'm sure it will come um
something will solve that i mean we're
waiting on 82.0
kind of still so we'll see how that goes
um but in terms of mass adoption then
right so
bitcoin has that narrative for it being
a store of value i think at this point
it's
easier to sell to your friends and your
family
pick bitcoin it's you know tesla picked
it so you know it's obviously
it can it's obviously uh credible but
how does one
sell eth right like it doesn't hold that
store of value narrative it just doesn't
um somebody that i used to work with um
always
said something which has always stuck
with me he said that bitcoin is digital
gold and then eth is
digital well i say digital that doesn't
work it's like digital amazon
um amazon but and it is a form of and it
is like amazon i think those are the two
that's the two best comparisons that i
can give so it's really hard to sort of
sell
sell that to somebody um because why why
does my friend down the road
um care about defy um
why does she care about deep i can
understand why those in more developing
countries that don't have the kind of
financial infrastructure that we have
um would definitely appreciate being
able to um
you know lend borrow and all these
things that
and decentralized finance can offer but
i don't i don't know
how you're supposed to sell that
narrative to the average
person other than the decentralization
narrative
and the need for daps and stuff like
that other than that i can't
work out how to sell that how would you
do it
yeah so i think to understand it
properly as you said
probably the average joe on the street
won't won't get it in the same way
you kind of need to have an interest for
maybe finance and
know how things work in order to to be
able to understand
what possibilities there are with eth so
definitely it's not that easy to sell in
as uh as bitcoin i agree with that but
if people have interest for
for finance and and how all that works i
think it's
like they will understand it right away
um because basically what
is it's it's programmable money it's
it's super cool if you think about it
it's it's interesting so i'm just going
to jump in though because
when j when uh jk rowling got as if that
just slipped out of my head
when jk rowling um was like what's
bitcoin can someone explain it to me
people use that term it's programmable
money
and she's like what on earth does that
mean but literally like what does that
mean
you know like how do you break down the
term programmable money
yeah that that's that's one topic in
itself but if you think about it it's
just
what everything is it's just a line of
like code basically in
on the blockchain it's it's not more
more than that
and yeah i i don't know
i always settle i always settle for the
for the amazon argument the way like
um you can do all sorts of thing on
amazon you know you can watch movies you
can
buy books you can um get a kindle
you can buy all sorts of different
things i think
does amazon have music now do they have
like a spotify
equivalent i think they do probably yeah
i'm not sure yeah i think they do i'm
not sure
but that's the best way that i explain
it when i say programmable money i'm
just sort of like you can program it to
do
many different things um that's the only
way i can put that forward
but i know that narrative didn't stick
with uh jk rowling very well yeah
so what i would ask like instead like
what what is
fiat money then if you think it's just a
bunch of numbers on
on a like spreadsheet that's all it is
it doesn't have anything behind it
nothing it's just people type in numbers
on a spreadsheet that's
all what it is so at least with bitcoin
or
ethereum well bitcoin specifically its
program we know there will only be
21 million this there are specific ways
to
acquire it there are specific ways to
transact it and
yeah i mean it's so much more secure no
one can tamper with it
and and all that so i i guess maybe
that's a way
to explain that program money it's
it's a secure no one can tackle with it
but regular money it's just a bunch of
numbers without yeah
what you can manipulate as easily as you
want i don't know maybe that's
that's the way to put it yeah no i get
that and i think i think
this uh i say this year i think last
year and this year is definitely
one of the most amazing kind of use
cases or sorry case studies even
um to show somebody in terms of
manipulating the price of money
printing more money and all these sorts
of things um
and i think that idea of you know having
that hedge against inflation because
even when you look at something like
gold
there's always more gold to be mined
and i think that the value and the
scarcity obviously comes from the fact
that it's
it's scarce and it's difficult right
like you literally need to you can go
you know you have to go into the sea you
have to go into the ground um
there's and there is enough i read
enough
um gold up in the sky or down but
in space where everyone put it up down
everywhere um
on an asteroid to make everybody on
earth a billionaire but the interesting
part of that
fact is that if we if we then had access
to all that gold the value of it would
would just drop anyway so there's really
not enough to make everybody a
billionaire
but anyway i'm going on one but that's
kind of the argument that i that i
always put forward and
that's kind of why i never understand
people like peter schiff for example
who who just can't who just can't get on
it
um i don't get it i don't know whether
it's i don't know whether it's
um a generational thing um i'd like to
think not
something um that i saw somebody say
the other day i can't remember who it
was um i have no idea who it was maybe
somebody in the comments
will tell me when i say but they said
something like the next generation or
even our generation right we find more
value in things like spotify
um than vinyl records and cds and things
like that
um so looking at bitcoin and gold i
think it's kind of
going to be like that i think it's a
generational thing where if you're
trying to explain bitcoin as a digital
store of value to the next generation
then i think they're going to be able to
understand bitcoin better than gold
and particularly just given how easy it
is to store
it's portable and so on
yeah i agree and i don't i don't think
that gold is like a bad investment it is
good but it's nearly not as good as
bitcoin in my case but with peter schiff
specifically
he's like completely rejects rejecting
uh bitcoin which is yeah
that's like the the weird part about him
but there's nothing wrong about
like having gold as a store value
because yeah
it's it's a good store value it's all
right nothing nothing wrong with that
but uh yeah
his case is a little bit funny and the
funniest part is that his son is like
super intimate
and so i mean it's probably a
generational thing with him at least i i
do think
like that because i do see other like
older
relatives that i have they they have
really difficult time to understand
bitcoin the goal with gold it's like
yeah you understand it so
at some point i do think that it is
generational
but at the same time every can everyone
can do and read
and learn more about it until we
understand
but it's just a little bit more
difficult and i think it's natural um
that it is that way
i mean john's really funny about it it's
not just
it's not just the likes of peter schiff
who reject it but it's also
um people that just don't understand
the value in it and why we think it's so
amazing so
like i'm going to take my dad as an
example um
when tesla bought 1.5 billion
i turned around to my dad and was just
like can you believe it like they put
this much money in
um and he was like oh okay so when are
you selling
and i'm like this is the time to hold
because this is when you hold this is
when people foam i win i'm like
what do you mean when am i selling and
he's just like oh you know things go up
and down and you don't want i'm like
this isn't the stock market this is
different this is it's that narrative
and it's not i just don't think it's
really hitting home to some people um
i don't know have you what experiences
have you had with your family have you
also found that it's not quite
hitting home yeah i i guess so
my dad gets quite well i think but he's
not at that point that he would invest
in it because he doesn't understand it
that much uh
so i would say i'm i'm a little bit the
the outsider
in my family who who wants uh all in
or in crypto but of course they are like
very supportive and
yeah they didn't try they understand the
basics i would say
but i yeah they probably wouldn't be
able to explain
the difference between bitcoin and eth
to some of their friends
or like that um but when it comes to
yeah
um yeah i lost my thread okay i thought
that's all right
les i want to go back i want to go back
to tesla to be honest because i want to
just talk about what you think
that means for the space so who do you
think is going to get in next so
i've been reading a lot into this i know
that apple are rumored to
get in next um that's according to um i
think it was the royal bank of canada
um so they're rumored to get in next um
twitter's cfo said on cnbc today
that they aren't necessarily looking i'm
sorry not twitter um
uber sorry uber said on
um cnbc today that they aren't
necessarily looking to put bitcoin on
their balance sheet but they
are considering um people accepting
um payments for uh in crypto for rides
so what are your thoughts on that
yeah i think it's well first of all
because tesla is
the role model probably for many
companies and um
so many cfos probably are scanning
around what are other
companies doing and they see of course
also micro strategy like how much gains
they have made after they put bitcoin on
their balance sheet so
of course now they need to look in it
it's their responsibility to look into
it if we see that there are companies
that are
doing this that are successful of course
they need to do it i mean if they don't
do it
they're not good cfos i would say uh so
and i think of course as well it's
easier for for companies like uber who
are
i mean they are digital so they kind of
understand probably the product better
as well so
more companies like that will i'm sure
look into it
um and twitter of course we know that
twitter's
previous yeah ceo um
is a bitcoin so that's that was quite a
amendment
um but probably more like big
unicorn startups uh will will look into
it i'm sure
because they also have the pressure now
from from shareholders and and others
uh to for for them to perform well so
they need to take the responsibility and
and look into it
and that that's yeah definitely who it
is i think a key word there is
responsibility actually it's a really
good word to use
because these people these companies
do have a responsibility for their
shareholders to be putting their money
in the correct place and
bitcoin is now something which people
sort of agree
can't be ignored you know if the richest
man in the world
um is he the richest man in the world
i'm not sure i think like he's
fluctuating like bitcoin's price
um but i i don't know he he is he is for
a minute and then he's not and then he
is and then it is up and down but yeah
if they're putting on their balance
sheet then i do i can imagine the
when that was announced you probably
have like cfos running around like
opposites just like oh my god what do we
do like should we be copying this should
we be doing the same thing
um i i think it's insane but another
really interesting topic
um that i want to get your thoughts on
is regulation um it's a really cool
topic i like
um because there's um kind of this push
and pull in the community between
regulation being necessary to take
bitcoin to the next level
um and then and then but also what about
freedom and
um you know people's anonymity and like
forget kyc
and all this stuff so when um well i
spoke to raul powell and
he is a no okay i don't say he's a fan
of regulation he's not read the point
he's more
talking about the importance of it to
take bitcoin to that next stage he sort
of says
if you want bitcoin to become that
that's
that that asset that store value that
currency or whatever you want to call it
that
major players are using more regulations
could be necessary so
there hasn't been a change in regulation
yet bigger players are getting in so
where do you stand on regulation
and it's necessity uh to take bitcoin to
the next step
um so in general of course regulation
means it's not always good but i think
it's it's also necessary as
as you mentioned before that it will be
a natural part
because now bitcoin is being getting big
billions of uh
like in corporations corporations are
investing billions so it it will come i
mean if you want it or not it will come
and at some point
it will do good as well because then um
other companies
will see that okay now it's actually
regulated now it's secure to invest in
it probably they will think
more that way and um so yeah
i think there's both good and bad to it
we
who have been in this space for a long
time and we've been here
and enjoying all the freedom that we
have we're probably not super big fans
of it
but i think there were of course parts
um that they really see that
this is what we need in order to get
into it so
yeah i think they're both good and bad
but
for bitcoin to become like really global
and really
uh like a normal part of a company's
portfolio or a balance cheat
i think it needs to be regulated yeah um
so um yeah there's two yeah first it
i can't really take one or the other
side i i don't know
because i think of course
yeah go for it sorry yeah no i think it
depends
i think it depends on what we want
bitcoin to be um
well that was kind of always my opinion
until
more people started getting in until
this week really until tesla and bny
melon
um bmy melon are one of the most
reputable oldest banks in america so
i find that fascinating um i really do
um
because it's because you see there's a
difference isn't there between tesla and
and y melon tesla's tesla's this like
new digital kind of like company that
does things in a futuristic manner so it
makes sense
um it makes sense you know given who
elon musk is and the things he's
interested
in and all that but yeah to have such a
traditional bank
take such a leap yeah so it is really
cool
um yeah i agree it's super cool but then
as well i don't know if you saw
uh i think it was earlier this morning
christine lagarde went out and said that
yeah that central banks having okay now
now this we're not talking about a
central bank but still it's a little bit
in in the same
um area that's yeah it's out of the
question that they hold
are going to be holding bitcoin and
that's actually like really
i don't know how how we will come across
that
or by that um but those are central
banks so that that's not the same thing
but
um still we do have some challenges to
to get through there are a couple of
questions i want to
i want to just uh answer so if anyone
has any questions feel free to
throw them now um i'll answer both of it
i'll give this to both of us um
so somebody says do you think bitcoin
will stay above 40k from now on
or do you think it will drop back to
lower levels
um do you want to go for that would you
want me to go for it first i can go
first so
i think staying around 40k is that we
will do that for for some time
um so now we are around yeah 47.3 i
think we might drop a little bit lower
uh to but but definitely about 40 for
for some time but then yeah we we might
hit
bear market again very soon depends on
uh how this um
alt c is going um but yeah it's
difficult to say
it's difficult to say at some point as i
mentioned
that i have people who were absolutely
not interested in bitcoin before
reaching out to me it's
it's kind of also a little bit of a
bearish signal for me because now it's
like everyone is in is this
you know sometimes i'm thinking tesla
got in we have more and more companies
joining
is this the top now i mean we don't know
it might be
it might be at least yeah that's that's
what i think so sometimes
uh i don't want to spread any fun but i
think you
would like that what are you no i i i
don't think so i don't think so i think
i think things are just heating up
honestly um can bitcoin drop below 40k
yeah of course you can drop like 40k um
but
will it drop below 30 i am less
sure about that given how we saw what
was it like in the 30s for was it a
month or three weeks or something like
that i felt forever
um but but but i think you know that
there's a lot of support between 30 and
40k
um which makes me feel um really
optimistic about those
price levels um regarding 40 plus
it's impossible to say it's absolutely
impossible to say i think
the only in my opinion the only reason
why we are nearly at 50k right now is
because of tesla's
um tesla's investment so we will have to
see
whether that holds we obviously saw as a
bit of a dip yesterday we'll have to see
how that holds um but
in my opinion um this is not financial
advice
but i think i think 30k could
potentially be the bottom and we're kind
of
here on out from there um here's another
interesting
question actually wait i'm going to ask
another one first someone says what are
your thoughts on nfts i know you're a
fan of nfts
liz yeah um
well i think it's super cool because we
we do see a lot of activity from uh
influential people when it comes to nfts
um
soulja boy's got one hasn't he yeah i
think so too yeah yeah i'm not
i haven't uh looked into that but yeah i
saw him tweet tweeting something
about i think but we had more cuban he
he were doing
he was doing um like short videos uh
yeah kind of nfc thing i think
uh who else do we have um what is it
paul logan is it paul logan what's his
name logan paul
like he was an nft and i'm not sure if
he but he was
into that he was actually like talking a
lot about uh that
and who else we had someone else as well
like hollywood uh hollywood star don't
tell me lindsay lohan's got an nft
i think she has i think i think she did
yesterday i'm honest
yeah probably yeah definitely i think
she
has an nft actually me and ivan were
discussing this
uh yesterday let's see let's i think she
actually hasn't
so i think this this is amazing that uh
like influential people are seeing the
use case of it i think it's super cool
and especially because this is something
everyone wants to
you know collect something either what
is and this makes
also like a physical product like i have
paintings or something
it makes it more special you know
because you kind of have a
a specific thing that is is connected to
that
what what you can follow so i think it's
super cool and i think this is also
something that people will understand
uh because you know we have pokemon
cards what are
all the things that people are
collecting so this is just
to have it in a digital way so i i think
it's actually
super cool and i think it will probably
only grow especially seeing now all the
activity and
people are getting yeah celebrities are
involved in it
so uh yeah i'm i'm a big fan of it and i
think
uh it will definitely be a part of like
everyday collectibles uh in globally
i think nfts so i'm really i'm really
kind of like drawn
um with nfts i'm kind of like torn sorry
in two different places so
firstly i totally understand the need to
um
put things on the blockchain um to
for authenticity purposes so i totally
get you know putting like um products
that say like
designer handbags ornaments paintings
and things like that you know giving
them
tokenizing them giving them um a place
on the blockchain
and then you can then you know for sure
okay well number one you know it's
history which is really important um
when it comes to
different things like i know because my
brother's a big fan of watches
i know that um no two no two watches
have the same value
where it was made where it comes from
and all this stuff affects the price of
it
so i can really understand the um the
importance of that
the only thing which gets me is um
it's like this is the selfies if i'm
really honest i don't get it i get that
it's fun to give it a go i'm so i'm so
for it
i just i'm i struggle and i spoke to um
coin artist marguerite about it and
i just i i can't get my head around it
just because it could just because the
the picture already exists online
so i always struggle to wrap my head
around the value
of it um i don't i don't know
i struggle yeah i agree with you i agree
with you but when it comes to
i have to tell you like i have to
confess i did sell an nft selfie that
was my first one
and that was right why not you know it
was just like i need to try it
and it actually goes it's super good but
now when i think about it after it's
like
don't don't buy a selfie i mean don't
don't
i don't see the value in it either i i
really don't uh
so yeah i i think that will probably die
out
soon that use case i think it already
has pretty much
but yeah that part i
i don't understand either well if you
can have like
because now what they do is all kind of
digital art and all that
which can be nice as well but you can
just still you know you can copy
um or print screen it and just you know
use it anyway but i think
when it comes to to give value when it
comes to
like you can have digital collectible
cards or something that actually has
some purpose in a game or something and
then
it's it's more usable and and i can see
a use case for it
but i agree with just a selfie and nah
it's hard it's hard like and i think i
think like they say about beauty i don't
know if this is a british term but i
always compare the two beauties in the
eye beholder and i sort of feel the si i
feel the same
um sentiment when it comes to nfts i
really think the
um the values in the eye of the beholder
like there's value in
anything whereby someone perceives value
in it so
whoever bought your selfie finds value
in it and that's super cool
um so maybe make another one um
definitely you know
if people find value in it then you know
offer offer a service whether
there's value i just find it i just
struggle to kind of figure
put my head up get my head around it
like i really get it when it comes to
products
um and even even documents for
for houses and things like that and and
even even like domains somebody wrote in
the comments
um about unstoppable domains um i get
that as well i really get it um i just
struggle when
um when it seems like selfies just
because they've already been posted i
don't know maybe it's just me
um but somebody else put in the comments
um a really cool topic um about earning
interest um so i will try to find the
question
because i can't remember where it is but
someone asked about how can you earn
interest
um on your cryptocurrency so i'll kick
that one off
um okay um can you speak about earning
interest on cryptocurrencies okay it's
pretty straightforward so
i'll kick that off i mean i earn up to
8.6
interest right now um on my usdc in
block five
um i use block fi they do sponsor the
show i'm really open about that um but i
actually use them so i definitely put my
money where my mouth is
um and i i think they're really great
they pay you monthly
um you can get up to 250 when you sign
up um
you can get you can put bitcoin in there
you can put litecoin in there i believe
i think they just it's either litecoin
or ethereum they just
increased the amount of interest you can
you can make on there
so i i'd recommend them um
if you want to earn interest uh the bank
of england i believe
so we can get we can get this
interesting one so the bank of england i
think i've just gone down to zero
interest i can't remember i think it was
at 0.01 now it's completely gone just
because of
korean virus and all that but you're
dealing with negative interest rates
over there aren't yeah
yes i think for the last what is it five
years something yeah it's it's horrible
but it's everyday life here now so yeah
that was
what i wanted to to like answer right
away like earning interest yeah that's
that's nothing that
we do regular people do in sweden but of
course there are other ways to it
and i have to say that i'm not that um
like um
i don't know about that many um like
opportunities to earn interest when it
comes to group
except blockify blockfi actually because
i did research them one time and i have
had a meeting with someone from their
team who explained it really well and
and yeah so i think that's definitely
one of the
the best ways to take a look at if you
want to to earn it
uh and yeah the problem which do you use
what do you use
so block file you use yeah yeah so
that's the
like basically the only one i i know but
but there are more
nexo i think or what what are the more
um
so you can use crypto.com as well um
yeah
but there's there's quite a lot but the
fees are different
um and you have to so with crypto.com
you can choose to
um get more in to get more interest so
you can get a high percentage if you
lock in for three months so
it really it really depends um so
there's another question here
um about link which i think is um oh
yeah celsius by the way guys there's a
good one someone's just dropped that
below celsius is also a really good one
alex missions he's cool so oh that's
true that's true
um that's a good one um okay wait
somebody asked about link
so i can chat about link i don't know do
you want to give your thought thoughts
first or join me to go through it
you can go ahead i don't yes so i think
i think link's really interesting i hold
link i'm always really open about what i
do and don't hold
um i don't know whether i think it's
interesting that's kind of like the
extent
to that i will say um i think if d5
really takes off i think right now d5 is
still very experimental um but if it
does
take off then i think um there is a need
for
um projects like link um
you know i think there is a i think
there's a need for it sorry
so link have that first mover advantage
um so i know there are obviously
competitors like band protocol and so on
but link do have that first mover
advantage so
if d5 takes off then link is going to be
that what already is that go-to
um but i don't know because it's still
really experimental um is that ivan
behind yeah that was live online yeah
hey ivan hello yeah
that's cool um so yeah those those
those are my thoughts on link i don't
know if you if you're watching any other
alts other than you
i i do watch and but i don't hold any uh
link i have to say that right away i
have thought about it but i feel like
i'm a little bit late to the party
probably not but
it just feels like a little bit too late
but i totally understand the
like oracle networks and all that it's a
good purpose and all that so i think
we'll definitely perform
good probably and so um yeah um
but i don't hold it okay what are you
holding someone's asking what's in your
bag ladies
so yeah mostly bitcoin and eat but i
also do have um
other smaller old say i have poo i do
have what else what else uh
now since recently i have also execute
or create
damn so you're you're really bitcoin
underneath then if you can't think of
your head you're really big for the knee
yeah yeah i think i don't have anything
else yeah but i'm really really big
underneath yeah
um definitely because i think like long
term
and that's that's nice to hold i think
with all
uh yeah you can make really good games
uh you you can
um but um you really need to also like
all the time follow and it's a little
bit stressful um but yes
yeah if you find like projects you like
of course uh probably now thinking that
i should have um
got into polka dot before i don't know
it's like it's too late but i know i
remember like
yeah but yeah i know i know but i i kind
of feel like i don't know if if we
really have
like topped now because we do do you see
a lot of balls performing
like crazy well so i'm gonna we're in
the hospital market as well so
yeah yeah yeah so i'm a little bit
cautious but i remember i was looking
into dots
in september and yeah i should have got
it but no
it's all right it's right i love my
bitcoin and eat so it's all good
that's good that's good i think uh when
people ask who i own so bitcoin and eth
obviously
um and then i do own a few alts um but i
don't watch them at all so i own ada
right
and um somebody that i follow tweeted
that ada was up and i was like oh my god
like i haven't even looked at that
yeah i don't i don't watch them i just
have them um
because i don't because because i don't
know i was just like playing around so i
bought a few so
i bought link i bought ada um i hold ics
um because i am a fan of the project um
i do quite a bit of work with them
everyone knows i'm quite open about that
um and oh
this is a strange one that i own again
this isn't financial advice
but i own one which is um harmony's um
native token just because just because
um
back in july last year i was supposed to
do um
an interview with them so i was like
i'll buy some um so i bought some and
nothing's really happened
um i wonder if i'm missing any i own
blue as well obviously i own crow
because i use crypto.com
oh i don't i should own vt but i don't
um
that's always that's always a really
good one um
so there you go all right we're coming
up to an hour we've been chatting for uh
for a while
wow time flies me neither really
someone asked me why why did my youtube
video get removed
yes yes i want to hear that because yeah
this is always frustrating
why well i'm not entirely sure why it
got removed it was literally
a um it was literally a
60 second tick tock video um just saying
that guys elon musk's company tesla put
1.5 billion
in um this will make this will solidify
bitcoin
as a store of value um blah blah blah
credibility la la la
yeah um and it was doing well like it
was doing well i saw that video
yeah there you go yeah yeah i was
thinking like oh good you're posting
your tic-tac videos on youtube
and yeah yeah okay so that one got
removed what the heck
yeah well and they they didn't really
say they were like it's misleading and
i'm like everything is
really factual here i was like
everything got on and they still haven't
gone back to me
um it's a bit upsetting to be honest
because you know you we i know people
talk about oh
you should move to here you should move
to there and we should but
it it's just hard when there's a big
audience obviously
um and i know somebody has to take the
first step and i appreciate that but i
think
it yeah it's it's difficult to move off
of youtube so
um what are you still waiting to hear
back
yeah i i guess so and this is your first
video
getting removed right now yeah yeah so
it's probably you know sometimes they
they just haven't
like they do it automatically without
thinking and i agree
moving to another platform it's easier
said than done
you kind of still have your audience
there so it will really require
like um a lot of uh struggles because
usually you get straight going a bit oh
yeah but you you you
it wasn't they didn't even say but they
they didn't say they said we're not
giving you a strike
we we just i think they thought it was
like spam or something
um and i'm like what there's so much
spam on there how are you
how are you doing we spam when there's
so much ram on that i don't know
they should like seriously work with
their ads because i see this uh like
metallic scam
ad all the time when i watch i don't
have any youtube premium so i see that
and all the time they should work more
on that because that's really bad like
the scammers
right now really bad i don't know if you
saw but i had like there's a lot of
people
impersonating me and i had two guys
reaching out to me yesterday and they
will literally like send a thousand
bucks to like a bitcoin liz
yeah they did like two confirmed cases
there might be more because it's kind of
embarrassing to
admit that that you did it because yeah
i mean
yeah it's insane so and they were like
complete newcomers to the space
uh and i feel really really bad for them
but this is unfortunately this is
reality in crypto you need to be
cautious uh
if something seems too good to be true
it is a scam probably
so yeah they they lost their funds like
fortunately it's
it's not that much money but still it's
significant to to some people so
yeah yeah just on that point though so
here's something that i experienced and
i want to let you know and i'll see the
audience as well because
i experienced a weird one so there was a
scammer
um and then somebody with a really
really weird account who had literally
just joined um so this happened in
january or december i can't remember
um but somebody who let's say it was
january somebody who had just joined
um that january january 2021 dm'd me and
was like
there's a scammer of you um how dare you
not tell the community that there's a
scam review you owe people money now
people have lost money because of you
and i'm like are you the scammer i was
like are you trying to get
me you know so
it was really really odd like he he took
like a real personal kind of
interest in what was going on um and
he'd literally just joined
he'd just joined twitter um as soon as
this whole thing had kicked off so i was
kind of just like
i need to block this person you're quite
threatening yeah um
because i mean there's so and i don't
know if people know but like
so liz you have hundreds of fake
accounts
it's unbelievable they have like 12 000
13 000 followers
i know it's insane i have seen like two
of them
one has twelve thousand one thirteen and
it takes time i know they have been
around for weeks and i've asked
like everyone i know around me to to
report it but still they have been up i
think
now one of them at least is gone but
it's insane
it's and it's impossible to stay up at
all it's impossible keep posting so
i think and what i've noticed a lot of
people do they just leave it now
um and just sort of hope that everybody
just gets the gist when you're right
when you're in crypto this sort of
happens
um so yeah i don't know i thought it was
really strange this guy just
pressuring me to announce this and that
otherwise i owe people money i was like
wow this is
uh yeah probably was probably was a
scammer he wanted you to say or he or
she wanted you to say something specific
that
he or she can use against you or
something but yeah
they're getting smarter and more clever
literally they are getting smarter so
guys please be mindful um
liz and i will never ask you for money
nobody will ask you for money nobody
will ask you for any private details
nobody will ask you um for any sensitive
information where you live
and so on so and if it like liz said if
it does sound
too good to be true it probably is and
also here's a funny one
if they start the message off with how's
your trade going
yeah big red flag yeah
big real conversation like that anyway
where can people find you what are your
final words yeah so
everyone can find me on twitter um liz
bitcoin and
youtube i've started to upload a little
bit more like short videos when i feel
for it uh it's also a bitcoin list
there and instagram as well but
mostly twitter and youtube now yeah
it has been great hanging out with you
it was fun
yeah it's been great having you thanks
so much for joining me
um it's been super chill um thank you
everyone for watching and thank you so
much for your comments
and your questions it's been really nice
just to keep it casual have it keep it
nice and informal
so you go guys thanks so much for tuning
in liz thanks for coming
and thank you to my sponsors i will see
you all next week
on thursday peace
[Music]
[Applause]